each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
yes a professor it makes me Leslie the
buzzer thank you the good morning go to
I've spent some time this morning
talking about zorp which is a extensible
IP router software stack that we've been
working on for the past I guess about
five years now this is going to be the
research spin on this rather than the
marketing spin I hope that's the right
one for this audience if you want the
marketing talk i can do that one but
it's probably much less interesting so
basically we're gonna start off by
trying to explain a little bit about why
we bother to do this in the first place
and then go through the technical detail
about how we actually try to design
rudra software to be extensible why that
matters and so the design decision so
that's entailed which wait life harder
for us but I think in the long run
they're going to be really valuable um
what we came into this was somewhere
back in 98 99 a load of those netware
research were bemoaning the fact that it
was increasingly hard to do network
research and the research that was
happening was getting increasingly
divorced from reality if you went along
to nanog you hear one complete story go
along to sig comedy here in different
story and they just were not
intersecting at all and this is a bit of
a problem there's really two seem that
they were getting a particularly big gap
in the in the area that involved the
core of the network especially routing
and that sort of stuff and if you look
back through sort of the the 80s and so
forth pretty much all of the important
internet protocols came out of
universities or the research labs and
what happened with basically people
built stuff they tried it out some of
the work some of them didn't the ones
that survived Endor Getty standardized
that's not really the way things happen
anymore if you look at sort of this gap
between what's happening in research and
what's happening commercially there's a
bunch of different reasons for this the
principal one is really that the
internet became commercial and so the
stability of the network became really
important and experimentation became
more and more hard to actually do in a
real network
if you look at the likes of Cisco and so
forth the major infrastructure vendors
they're not really motivated to support
experimentation they don't need to but
also it's not where their money comes
from their money comes from the ISPs and
if you look at what happened in the
research labs throughout the world as
this problem started to evolve the we
started to move towards doing a lot more
working simulation there's probably a
few people doing congestion control
research for example there having been a
lot of working simulation and also in
routing and so forth and the network
simulate has got quite good but
economies that simulation really isn't a
substitute for experimentation there's a
lot of questions you'd like to ask that
you can't answer unless you've actually
got either real-world traffic or
real-world routing information that sort
of stuff and if you look at what happens
in a lot of universities PhD students
basically give up the implement their
stuff in NS NS has a million parameters
don't really play within us but it's
like how you set these parameters is to
a large extent guesswork because there's
not enough information about how the
real networks function be able to set
the parameters correctly it's not that
the students are stupid it's the there
isn't enough information to go on and so
that the end result is that the the
researcher gets published may or may not
bear any relation to reality so the key
here is we really would like to be able
to run experiments in real networks but
of course we've got this problem with
not be able to do that for a whole bunch
of different reasons now if you look at
where the state of the art is with
network research and actually trying
things out for the M systems this isn't
really such a big deal the open API is
that you have on on all operating
systems basically let you do protocol
research that uses those API so things
like sip which I was fairly heavily
involved with RTP and so forth that was
a subnetwork research is very easy to do
it's no real problem with that kind of
stuff even the stuff that involves
colonel changes things like TCP sac or
the igmp v3 work you've got open source
operating systems that lay you
experiment with that there's also quite
a good history of experimentation on the
transfer protocols and so forth out of
the commercial lab sir including here of
course but the real question here is
what about the protocols that affect the
roofers and if you look back to where we
started in this whole process there are
really two options you had the first
option was you went to Cisco and you
persuaded them to implement your
protocol they now shipped an
experimental iOS core uvas weighed the
ISP to actually try that out and and
convince them that there are there
reasons are not going to crash and
they're not gonna lose lots of money in
your experiment your other option was
basically to implement the routing part
in one of the available open source
routing sex mrt d gate d quagger so
forth implement the forwarding part in
your favorite operating system or and
some of these extensible forwarding
paths now persuade a network operator to
put your pc in place of their cisco and
run your experiment so how likely are
either of these two actually happen well
I'll tell that likely so this preface
with this problem it's really really
hard to actually manage to do this kind
of experimentation that we want to
Billie won't be able to play with voting
protocols we want to be able to play
with doing interesting things in the
forwarding paths and so forth and see
how they respond to real traffic so if
you look at the possible ways you can
solve these problems the first way
basically would be if the route event
has opened up there developed api's and
that would then let third-party to
actually develop for the existing
backbone routers unfortunately this
isn't really in the vendors interest
they certainly the big players not in
their interest in the small place don't
really matter as far as having any
impact the other option is basically to
try and get an extensible rodeo software
that actually out there and deployed and
so this place you would mean you'd have
to design a software stack it was
extensible that design it so its robust
enough for real-world use not just use
it in in universities and research labs
and so forth and once it gets to this
degree of robustness then you swayed to
some adventurous network operators to
actually deploy this stuff and over time
it gets more and more robust as people
use it in initially and probably in
research labs but more and more into
production used towards the edge and so
the goal here is that in the long run
you've got a platform actually out there
in the real world designed for
extensibility from the outset sure
so quagger is well firstly it was really
not going properly the time when we
started but the the second reason why it
doesn't really satisfy that is it was
never designed for extensibility the the
one thing that cragger does which is
fairly good for extensibility it's a
multi-process architecture so you can
put new routing protocols in there but
if you look at all the internal
communication that's happening in
configuration that it was not really
designed with this in mind so as I go
through my talk i'll show you how it
damages we made which very different
from what they did which we think really
will help as we go forward do you do yes
that's right and that requires
appropriate isolation boundaries
internally and inside that so that when
something goes wrong you limit the
amount of damage it can cause you can
never limit the amount damage to zero
but you can significantly reduce it
certainly if you're trying to do
experiments be something like iOS where
everything is in one memory space
basically anything goes wrong and
everything dies we can do a lot better
than that we probably can't get totally
to the point where you it read no risk
for doing experiment but we can reduce
that risk the the key really is that you
design this stuff to be extensible in
the first place but then yeah i guess i
guess this comes down to how effective
we can actually how effectively our
solutions actually solve these problems
and hopefully i'm going to convince you
that they solve the problems reasonably
well but that's I have to get through
the talk to convince you about
significantly better than the
alternatives don't a lot of work with
Cisco but the cisco have immense
internal problems on structuring of
their software anyway a better than to
talk to Abby juniper earthen Cisco
because they actually have an
architecture which internally has
appropriate isolation boundaries and so
forth and originally when we talked to
them they were they thought that they
might be able to go that path but it
seems that that's again it's not really
in their interests the they've succeeded
fairly well in in imaging to cover the
core ruta marketing to ajapa lee and so
so long as it is a duopoly then it's not
they don't have it as a particular
interest in checking that happened and
opening up platform to third-party
software vendor things like that but it
could happen i mean one of the one of
the options is that we successful that
we persuade them to do it and then
doesn't necessarily matter whether our
software runs or not because they've
already sold the problem although the
big problem of course is that this
doesn't really let the basic core reader
functionality get changed it might let
you spend with virgin protocols but not
necessary with the forwarding paths for
example so that would certainly be very
nice if they did i don't think it gets
us all the way to where we would like to
be but it's a lot better than where
we're at at the moment so going back to
this issue of how hard it is to actually
change the core of the network from ISPs
point of view stability really matters
and they can't afford these can't afford
problems they've basically not going to
run anything experimental on their
production Reuters if there's a high
risk of it actually affecting that their
existing traffic so you really need to
have appropriate at arm isolation
boundaries if you're ever going to get
to that particular position of course
early on I think there's very little
chance was actually getting any of this
stuff into the core of the network but
that's not necessarily such a big deal
because all of the interest evolution
women ceased to be happening at the
edges of the call
rather than right in the middle
observation here is actually building
routing protocols is really hard and
it's actually much harder than I thought
it was five years ago it's you you read
these specs and they don't seem all that
complicated but actually when you when
you come to really build this stuff it
is not at all easy there's if you look
at the sort of history of people trying
to deploy routing software the reason
why cisco and juniper do so well is
because nobody else actually does very
well their software is it gains a
reputation of being trusted over a long
period of time and we basically to get
to this in the sort of situation of that
but the big vendors don't really have a
lot to gain from innovation here because
because the ISPs can't afford to run
experimental code the vendors don't
actually want to bother putting the
effort into doing experimentation and so
forth the normal way this would change
in just about any other part of the
product space will be through startups
and that can't happen here and the
reason it can't happen here is because
this is a closed software market if you
buy your hardware from Cisco you have to
run Cisco's software on there and all
the redo protocols and then management
stuff and everything else similarly for
juniper and so forth so the end result
here is that there's a lot of important
problems that are that are cropping up
over the last five to ten years which
are really remaining unaddressed I mean
they're really serious issue with BGP
for example that it would be good to
actually get addressed and it's just not
happening because there's no real
incentive for the people who can make a
difference to actually make any change
so our hypothesis here and we'll see
whether we can convince you of this by
the end is that if you design for it
software for extensibility in the first
place that we can we can help solve this
problem again it's not a necessary a
complete solution but it takes it in the
right direction so this hopefully would
allow experimental deployment of new
routing protocols obviously the places
where this to Bill team at a little bit
less first and as they start to gain a
reputation stability then creeping out
further through the network there's also
a hope here that we might be able to
enable a market for rigid applications
which is something that doesn't exist at
the moment but it will be very
interesting
if you could actually do that if you
look at what's available really there
are extensible forwarding paths that
exist intel on a bunch of others put a
lot of work into network processors
there's an fpga-based forwarding paths
with a bunch of software stuff click
from from MIT Scouts so forth but really
very different work on trying to design
an extensible control planes it happened
the actual demands / software make this
actually pretty hard obviously the
stability requirement we talked about
Reuters are really doing a very
large-scale distributed computation
anything involve distributed computation
is hard so trying to design stuff that
is going to be stable and defensible at
the same time doesn't exactly make your
life easier if you look at the way
routing protocols are written the specs
and everything else a lot they're
written with an assumption or a very
tight coupling of functionality this
probably comes if more than more lengthy
else from sort of the legacy of
implementing it in a tightly coupled way
in in iOS which is where an awful lot of
these things that we have to deal with
now came from originally and the
protocols themselves were never designed
to be extensible so trying to actually
design software that's extensible for
things that weren't designed to send
from the first places is interesting in
its own right this is really hard
towards the end when i'll show you some
slides on evaluating this i'm not going
to show you any sides on how to evaluate
whether it being successful
insensibility because there is no really
good sort of quantitative metric for
that the best we can really do is is
anecdotal evidence that basically shows
that when people have tried to do things
with software that there were not what
we expected that they've generally found
it very easy they need to be able to
slip them straight in without any
changes to the rest of the code or that
it has required some changes but the
changes have been very minimal and easy
to do and that seems to be the best we
can do if you know of any other ways of
evaluating sensibility then please let
us know we'd like to know but we we
don't know of any so anyways this
basically brings us down to the for
challenge we're really trying to solve
with its trying to bay
so you build software site that has
sufficient functionality to actually be
deployed in the real world design it to
be extensible from the outset and and
one of the key things here is to try and
D couple the sensibility to avoid this
massive feature interaction problem you
get into whenever you deal with
extensibility so extensions perfectly
the coexist pretty gracefully
performance has to be good enough it's
not the primary criteria for control
plane software literally we're not
really dealing with core rotors but just
the edge rating problem is hard enough
and the even edge rate is often a deal
with fluid bgp feeds of 160,000 routes
and things like that so big routing
table size matters increasingly low
latency of routing really matters it
didn't use to but as voice over IP and
things that start to be a large amount
of traffic then it matters that if
anything changes that you recon verge
very fast then of course it's got to be
robust and that basically comes from
having a good a lot of good test Suites
and so forth but it also comes from
deploying it in the real world and
finally out all the really strange
things people do with voters that you
never would possibly expect an aside
here in the past a lot of the rigid
protocol implementations were scanner
based and so basically what happens then
is that periodically a scanner runs over
the routing table and accumulates
changes and and then notifies neighbors
and change the foreign table and so
forth this is easy to implement it
doesn't take much to get cpu utilization
and so forth but it has pretty poor root
convergence properties this didn't used
to matter but the market is really
changing people really want things to be
able to converge very fast when things
change so these days basically what the
the whole trend is towards event-driven
Roadshow implementations actually not
that many the imputation out there
event-driven but they're increasingly
going that way so basically when
something happens as far as possible you
process at events through to completion
immediately this means you really need
to be explicitly tracking the
dependencies between the different
pieces of functionality so this again is
something that it's harder to implement
and it's especially hard to implement in
an extensible manner so this is just
something to bear in mind that we're
trying to design things which are
event-driven from
outset yeah there's inevitably this
trade-off what you actually even the
scanner can get yourself into trouble
when a lot of things change but the I
think the balance in terms of control
plane if you look at the waist of the
CPUs evolved and the amount of CPU power
you have processing control stuff the
symptom doesn't apply for the forwarding
plane where band words have been growing
faster than Moore's law but in the
control plane the routing tables are
growing fairly fast but they're not
going anywhere near as fast as CPU
cycles that are available to throw it
the problem so I think the balance of
power has changed here that in the
control plane with AC we can do stuff
that is more expensive than we used to
be able to do and so whereas before you
really got concerned that you would
overload the rotor control plane because
when a large number of things happen you
won't be able to cope with it these days
I think that's the balance beam you
trying to make sure things converge fast
and trying to make sure you don't
overload your CPU comes down on the side
of being event-driven now that means
you're going to be fairly smart about
how you cope with overload and I won't
claim that we were smart as we need to
be go with that we with something that
we are aware of there being some issues
when we hope you have some proposed
solutions how to deal with that mostly
that come down to scheduling you've got
to have a pretty good internal designer
how you showed your stuff in the router
but that's getting ahead of myself here
okay so this is what I come to talk
about zorp which is our extensible open
roda platform this was we improved
basically all the main core unicast and
multicast routing protocols it's a
multi-process architecture everything is
event-driven as far as it is feasible
it's a bsd style license so you can take
the code and do whatever you want with
it the moment it's about 560,000 lines
of C++ about a fifth of that actually
his machine generated code from various
cub stuff so it's 400 and something
thousand lines of stuff that we've
actually written probably that another
40,000 to go in there with some other
things that have not yet being committed
to the main
archive so this is sort of stuff I'm
going to talk about today the main
contributions here are the stage design
of how we've built our routing protocols
they talk about our interpreters
communication mechanism and and how that
being scriptable is really a very nice
feature for us going to talk about how
you actually build an extensible
management framework for a root of how
dynamic extensible command-line
interface and the management software
and I'm going to talk about our policy
framework as well so we think that this
is basically the first foot first root
of software stack that's really been
designed from the outset thinking about
extensibility of being a high priority
and also being event-driven get the
stuff from there if you wish so this
gives you kind of a road map to the
different pieces of absorb there's
nothing desperately surprising about
this particular that over here we have
the different routing protocols for
unicast routing and for multicast
routing pimps pass mode igmp and so
forth they contribute routes into the
the rib the reading information base
which then arbitrates when you get a
route which is available through more
than one protocol and things like that
that passes through down to a process we
call for tianjin abstraction each of
these boxes on here by the way the
process the purpose of this is really to
give us a national Asian layer so we can
separate our functionality from the
platform we're actually implementing on
this turned out to be really really
useful when we suddenly got the bright
idea of implementing some windows the
management plane up here involves a
Rooter manager for starting and stopping
process and configuring things a
command-line interface SNMP and then
things for doing our enterprise this
communication here so this is basically
the roadmap of the different pieces of
the other software it's a multi-process
architecture so that so that when
something goes wrong in one particular
protocol there's a limited amount of
damage you can do to anything else and
then the inter process communication
mechanism between these processes is one
that we ended up advising ourselves
which was not something we said
to do in the first place but we ended up
there anyway and I'll talk about that a
little bit later as well yeah the the
answer is at the moment non because
there is not a specific requirement for
it in other words there is pretty much
never the case that you have a rotor
that actually deployed more than one
multicast routing protocol now what we
what we were probably done if we
actually were implementing more than one
is to basically do the similar thing for
it's a rib for for multicast but it's
very unclear to us at this stage exactly
what the requirements are such a box are
yeah the issue though is it's really
unclear what how you should actually
arbitrate between different multicast
roots there is no not at this point in
time anyway a consensus as to exactly
how to do that I know there's there's an
RFC that you wrote which says some of
this stuff but as far as I'm aware
nobody actually deploys it that way so
the answer is it's up in the air and it
didn't seem to be any point in actually
writing that piece without actually
having that part of the story now should
that requirement come up it's very easy
to simply redirect that arrow to point
to the the multicast rib well where we
actually accumulate roots at the moment
we haven't done it simply because there
isn't a requirement to do it so yes it's
it's the architecture were permitted it
would require that we actually cited
what such a rib should do and I don't
think that's terribly hard thing to do
so what we have is a we have a large
number of component tests which get run
for each of the different things we
build whenever we build something you
build the component test for it whenever
we find a bug the first thing we do
awful lot we try to stick this we don't
always succeed but we try is to actually
write the component test that identifies
the bug then fix the bucket and so we've
gained a very large number of these
component test for testing out the
individual components so that basically
prevents accidental regressions and
things like that which is pretty
important when you got a large code base
the the next thing we do is then we have
a bunch of tests which which 10 test the
whole protocols and this is all it's all
script driven and the fact that our
enterprises communication mechanism
script which I get on to another while
really helps us because we can write we
have a large number of Python and bash
grips which basically then can can drive
the input to all of these protocols and
test them all through a whole bunch of
different hypothetical scenarios without
having to have a real network there so
one of the things that we the FAA does
this is again loaded inside but anyway
and in a normal implementation of a
written protocol ospf would talk to the
network pgp would talk to the network we
talk to the network and so forth we
haven't done that these routing
protocols instead of talking to network
directly relay their communication
through the FAA they descend in post
course a semi this packet out of that
work that way this means that the
protocols themselves are very isolated
from the platform they're running on so
it makes it very easy for it to port
things in different platforms but
perhaps more important than that it
means that we can exercise the routing
protocols themselves in isolation we can
we can fire these IPC calls at them from
scripts to drive the inputs and test at
the outputs do what we would hope and
that really is a very nice flexible way
that we can actually do testing so we
can then do a lot of automated testing
if you check out as orb and build it and
type g mate check in the top level
directory it'll go through and run
hundreds of tests on the different
protocols exercising the protocols
inputs i'm seeing what what
after the other side and so forth and we
have a tinderbox which runs every murder
rates of six hours or something on about
eight different platforms now that go
through an exercise all of those
different scripts and checks that on all
these different platforms all these
tests actually pass and any time we
discover something strange going on we
then go add more tests to this so this
test this whole test we'd is growing as
we go on as we find strange things that
people do with protocols that we never
expected that answer your question okay
so I'm just on the introduction which
works so what I'm going to talk through
today is first of all natural to bit
about the routing protocol design how we
actually break these up in such a way
that you can extend them later then I'm
going to talk a bit about the management
framework and how we actually design
extensible management framework given
that we don't really know what people
are going to tram plug into it in the
future a third thing I talked about is
the policy framework and how to actually
build a policy routing framework when
you don't really know what people are
going to try and apply policy to in the
future and lastly I'm going to give it
just a few performance results which
were from the paper we had an STI
recently so that you can get an idea for
how well things work so the first
question I want to discuss with you
today is a question of routing process
design and basically how do you actually
go about implementing a routing protocol
in such a way that it can be extended in
the future and there's not normally been
done people when they design implement a
written protocol basically try to
implement exactly what the spec says and
they don't really think about the fact
that these things actually evolve but
also what we want to do is to encourage
that people Lucien so this matters more
what we're trying to do than even in the
commercial implementations if you look
at a conventional router in this case
I've simplified it down to this ratio is
running bgp which is the bluish color
here and rip which is the greenish color
here but normally most readers are
running more than this essentially what
happens in most readers is you have
incoming roots coming from from
neighboring routers and you end up with
a state machine by handling the the
communication with your rotors and they
contribute roots into
to a big pool of roots and then the
decision process for for rip basic looks
a trip roots and then besides which ones
win and pass them on to the neighbors
and also pass them down to reporting bgp
does a similar thing except for it not
only need to know about bgp routes but
it also needs to know about the IGP
information to be able to make its
decision so it needs information from
both pieces of this to be able to decide
what to tell its neighbors um and then
out of this the best fruits end up
getting passed on to the forwarding
engine so you look at this and you go
well how do you design that an
extensible manner because there's really
the sort of big accumulation here where
you've got all the data in William in
one place so this is a pretty tightly
coupled architecture and that performs
well but it's really hard to change
unless you understand exactly how
everything interact with everything else
and this is kind of the key lesson for
extensibility if something's going to
change something and they have to
understand everything else first they're
never going to be able to extend it real
I care in a safe manner you need to
isolate the amount of stuff somebody has
to know to be able to make a change down
to the minimum pieces of relevant
information so what we needed was an
architecture was going to allow us to do
future extension and minimize this
information somebody interested no and
we ended up choosing a dataflow
architecture here now this of course
given that Eddie Cola was it was that
icsi at the time this came out of the
fact that the Eddie had used the
dataflow architecture for the cliq
forwarding blast off in his case it was
it was roots it was packets that were
going through dead for architecture in
our case it's essentially routing
information is going through so
basically what our routing posters these
routing tables like a showdown whose
side are actually now composed of these
are dynamics more processes through
which roots flow and the interface to
each of these stages is is common so
that you don't actually need to
understand very much other than where
you need to plan min something in and
what things are going to go back and
forwards so I'll discuss this with it
with the example of BGP although it also
applies to other things we've done I'm
in BGP what we have basically is
information coming in for the pier so
you need stuff to handle the state
machine and so for dealing with each
pier then you have incoming filters
where you actually want to modify roots
or drop them if they don't pass whatever
your routing policy is so you end up
with a bunch of filter banks here the
roots come into a decision process where
also information from the rib comes in
about the igp distance and things like
that decide which of the best routes and
then fan those out again to the piers
and also back down to the rib to be used
for forwarding so that's a very simple
sort of breakdown of how BGP might be
spit into a data file architecture where
stuff is basically coming in flowing
through these stages and through so the
key thing about this diagram is that
each of the arrows on here is a point
for extensibility the wherever you want
to actually put something in here as a
point where you might be able to plumb
in new functionality to extend what's
going on now if all of those arrows were
different that then you'd have to
understand an awful lot to be able to do
it but in practice there not so what I'm
going to do is to zoom in on one of
these arrows and basically show you what
so what's going on there so here's an
arrow the key here is what exactly the
interface look like so essentially what
you have is messages which flow down the
pipeline and it's very simple you get
less you to say add root delete root and
so anybody's going to plumb anything
into this pipeline or later say is all
ok I need to implement advert and delete
root and pass the things on down the
pipeline as appropriate now the other
question is wherever it's stored if you
stall them after all the changes have
happened to them then it becomes
actually pretty hard to figure out how
extensions fit in because one of the
things you want to do with real Reuters
as opposed to a bunch of the pc
implementation just to reconfigure them
on the fly which means what the stages
are doing in the pipeline changes are
depending on how the configuration of
the rotor changes so what we ended up
doing was to actually not store the root
post modification but to store them
right back at the beginning and we saw
in each of the incoming appears a tree
of roofs and those are unmodified there
we store them on the rotor before you've
actually applied any filters to change
them or things like that now what this
means is that if any of the downstream
modules get get changed you then just
have to push the roots again to apply
those changes especially if you want to
reconfigure filters on the rotor which
is pretty common thing you need to be
able to do on production rotors so those
roots can only push down this basically
means that when you want to do a
decision as to whether this route winds
and so forth you need to be able to send
a request backup to another peer and say
do you have the copy of this route to
find out which one wins so you end up
with this look up route message was
proposed back upstream and the reverse
of the the ad group messages so going
back to this diagram now this lets us
put new functionality through these
advert messages flow down look up route
measures come back up and you can put
new functionality that engine any of
these individual stages if you want to
change how the reefer actually functions
but if you look at this diagram there's
one thing on this diagram which is
complicated enough this decision process
it's taking information in from the rib
it's taking a fraction which means these
piers and the problem this with this is
it 10 it turns out that this stuff is
asynchronous each of these are just a
flow but this actually needs to
sometimes look up information in the
rear bit needs to send stuff out also it
turns out that one of the big problems
where the architecture like BGP is that
the rate at which you can send stuff to
your peers varies depending on network
congestion how fast they are and so
forth so you end up having to queue
stuff and if you accused of multiple
times we appear then things go get
pretty hairy pretty fast so the point at
which you need accused I've turned out
to be back here otherwise you've read a
memory very fast if you have a large
number appears so we enter a decomposing
decision again so now the decision
process is very simple stuff comes in it
sends the relevant lookups figure out
whether it wins or not and then send
leche is downstream and then there's a
certain another set of stages go in here
to do looking up of the BGP next top
information so a route will come down
here and it will get to here and all I
do I know about that next hop and if it
does it will pass it through and Suffolk
and if it doesn't then it gets pause
here temporarily while we do a lookup
so this now it doesn't have to do
anything asynchronous now much much
simpler and we also put a queue in here
which is how we deal with the fact that
you know stuff can come in fast and it
can go out and we have to be able to
deal with that and not blow large
amounts of memory on killing stuff
individually for reach of the peers so
it turns out it's actually there are
more stages in this in our real
implementation but this gives you a good
idea of how we've actually gone about
design itself extensibility now when we
were doing this we had sort of missed
something when we first thought about
this problem right back about five years
ago and so we've just shown you the
first half of that diagram the problem
now is what happens when this peering
goes down across the network failed or
the Navy Road a failed or whatever
something went wrong this guy can have
an awful lot of routes toward there it
fits if it's a bgp feed moment it would
have 160,000 roots or something so there
so the first problem is that you can't
actually did 150,000 routes
instantaneously and we're trying to be
event-driven here so you there are some
events you just can't actually process
through to completion the second problem
is that the the peering may come up
while we're still deleting those rooms
they may go back down and they come back
i may go down and you can see how this
will get really complicated really fast
if you have to deal with all of that
sort of thing so i was bemoaning how
we're going to do this and then Austria
came up with it was a really nice
suggestion which what we do is we take
that entire written table we take it out
of the the peer in and add a new routing
stage there pop that routing table back
into that this is now ready to handle
anything else that happens this has the
the original reach fruit tree of the
abridged we learnt there and this can
now go off and do what it wants in the
background deleting things as
appropriate as fascinated sensibly can
given given the CPU resources we have
available but it's not actually having
to to deal with trying to do this stuff
all in one go because the we're now able
to just go off and
new things and so the peering is now
ready for roots to come back up this
ability to do these dynamic stages is is
just a really nice flexible thing in
this architecture he lets you handle all
sorts of things that you wouldn't easily
be able to handle in a very simple
manner we use a similar way when we're
trying to when a new painting comes back
up we stick in the stages so that stage
is responsible for telling that neighbor
all about all the new roots and once
once they all the existing we'd rather
and once the the neighbor now is updated
with all of the state then that stage
can go away again so I just showed you
that in the case of BGP in the case of
our rib we use a very similar stage
design we actually do the pairwise
merging of things here which actually
provides even more different places you
can actually put extensible
functionality in with bgp you can't do
that kind of pairwise merging of roots
because well bgp is physically broken
but you really need to know all the
possible alternatives to make a decision
because i won't go into by bgp have
broken it is and then what this lets us
do is to have other routing protocols
register interest in roots of match
certain criteria and so we can add these
different dynamics ages into the ribs so
that we can inform the other routing
protocols about subsets of the roots
things that match the different criteria
here um I can talk about exactly how we
do that later on if you want but I was
not going to go and do that today okay
so that's basically this as a staged
architecture for trying to implement
routing protocols which we believe
actually gives us a lot of flexibility
in terms of how to implement things
moving on the next thing we want is to
be able to design an extensible
management framework for our ages and if
you look at how railroaders they use you
basically want to have a single
configuration file for a Rueter has to
be able to configure all the
functionality bgp rip new experimental
routing protocol forwarding well that
sort of stuff from one configuration
file because that's just the way I
operate interact with ridges they deal
with it as a whole although a software
developers we have to deal with the
region as a series of components so what
this means is we can't
separate command line interfaces for
those components we can't have separate
configuration files for them and so
forth we have to basically deal with
this stuff as one we have to do that
even though we don't know what's good
more people are going to come up with in
the future what we really like is to be
able to drop in new routing protocols in
the future from new vendors experiments
whatever and we want to be able to drop
those in without having to change any of
the core code in ins or they just want
to be able to run our command line
interface it now aware of their
existence and can do all of that sort of
thing so to explain how we do that first
of all I have to explain a little bit
about our interpreters communication
mechanism as I say we didn't really
intend them start out himself to write
our own IPC mechanism we ended up kind
of getting forced that way through a
whole different bunch of different
requirements we had on the problem but
what we have is what we call xrl zort
was also caters and these look very much
like urls for the web and for those of
you who who remember the web in in 1992
1993 the great thing about the web back
then was actually unified things like go
for an a and all of those sort of things
into one framework and what we were
trying to do in za was to be able to I'd
integrate all sorts of other pieces of
code we managed we have however whatever
protocol it was you'd use to actually
configure that this is one of the
reasons why we ended up going for things
which have similar properties to two
URLs the fact that they can actually
address different transport protocol
different ways of configuring things in
the end it turned out that actually the
thing that really mattered was that
these are asking all these to have a
canonical ASCII representation and
that's been the most useful thing about
them so anyway we end up with things
like this which basically that's a
canonical asking representation of an ex
RL the ways implement internally most
the time is actually in a faster binary
form but there is a the dispersion works
so basically there's a part of this we
basically what the transport is find a
basic as we don't know what the
transport is yet needs to be actually
resolved then that can be implemented
over TCP UDP
you can implement a xrl protocol family
to send signals to processes that sort
of thing there's a module Who am I
actually trying to communicate with oops
yeah of that feature about wood there's
an interface name which is a specific
interface that a module might support
some modules of some interface might be
spoiled on multiple modules some modules
much for multiple interfaces and so
forth then obviously the bit that's out
to really matter that the method we're
trying to call in this case we're trying
to set the autonomous system number on v
GP and then any appropriate parameters a
type parameter list for the type of
thing so that then gets fired off by the
process trying to make the call and the
result finder basis as well how do i
resolve that into a particular transport
protocol with the appropriate parameters
so in this case it's got resolved in
something to transport it over TCP with
the relevant port name and an IP address
this also means of course that it can
actually work over the network our
internal communication can work over the
network so we can build distributed
readers if you wish and anything else
that it by doing terms of managing the
method name and so forth do we support
v6 addresses in there I don't even know
if we do or not at the moment I just
about over they have influenced most of
it I don't think we do at the moment
yeah
it's basically the same as happens with
with URLs and they have the same problem
there's a syntax for those two it's it
only syntax and syntax could be can be
revised so the original strong
motivation for trying to do this was
that we wanted to be able to support
extensibility by dealing with non-native
communication mechanisms with things so
examples here might be sending signals
to processes or using SNMP and you
couldn't then integrate something need
to be configured through SNMP through
exactly the same in terms of
communication framework and the EXR a
library with them hi that's how I
communicated actually happening from
processing you wouldn't have to care
about that it's actually turned out that
the biggest advantage of this has been
the fact that they have a ask a
canonical representation which was a
surprise to us it wasn't what we
expected but what this means is that we
can build these tests harnesses by by
basically being to call these XR l's
from scripts there's a little piece of
C++ code for call X around which takes
one of these on the command line and and
you can basically script this stuff to
do all that kind of testing um the other
thing that it enabled us to do was to
design our route and manager process in
such a way that it can just take a
configuration template file for each of
the processes on system and learn how to
actually control it so what this does is
when you when you introduce a new
routing protocol enters or you put a
binary obviously to run but you also put
one of these template files you simply
says these are the things that can be
configured on this process and these are
the XR l's you can actually use to
configure them so this is a very very
small snippet out of a absorb
configuration file and this is a very
similar syntax for juniper use on their
routers it's just the usual sort of
hierarchy of things you would actually
configure but then for this ospf
instance you then end up with a with a
configuration template file which
basically says well these are the things
you can configure under the protocol
ospf part of the configuration you can
configure on ospf area it's going to
have to be a variable stuck in here but
it have that type and then for each area
you have inter interfaces where they're
going to be interfaced name we should
have type text and so forth and then
I'll me to the interfaces you can
specify the hello interval which is
obviously it's an integer but then for
each of these different things you want
to configure then that you can say okay
the way you configure that is basically
to use an ex RL and you fire off this
xrl and you embed the relevant variable
names from this stuff in this xrl do the
configuration and this is a ski template
files are very easy to write but it
means that we don't have to the rota
matter itself has to know nothing at all
about anything is going to control all
it has to do with know which directory
to go to load all the different template
files in and suddenly it knows
everything needs to know about how to
configure one of these new protocols
that's on the system which is really
very sweet and if that will allow
hopefully in the future people to write
third-party routing protocols to run on
a rotor you ship somebody the
executables for the for the rigid
protocol you should somebody the ASCII
template file you put it in their own
directory and suddenly you've extended
the configuration interface of the whole
system so that's a whirlwind tour of the
the management and how we try to make
the management part of the system
extensible so next question was how do
you actually go about trying to build a
policy routing framework that's
extensible and again you don't know what
the routing protocols are going to look
like that you going to be all the one to
configure so the first question is well
what is routing policy because I know
not everybody really has a good idea of
routing policy well here's a pretty
picture that's basically all I want to
convey here is the network is really
complex and if you think that the
network actually has nice regular
topologies and things like that you look
at these kind of maps and you go not
really this is a rotor level map of the
internet from six years ago here from
Qaeda is a autonomous system level map
of the internet which basically shows a
longitude around the outside and
connectivity going into the middle and
you look at this map and you go hmm now
I can't really tell much from that
either so when it comes to routing
policy and so forth we've said to think
of things like this which as you can pre
she ate bears very different
relationship to the real world but this
is the way we think about things in
terms of different tiers of ISPs the
real world maps into this to a
reasonable degree but not completely so
first of all you to explain very briefly
how bgp works for those of you who don't
miss turns on a bgp and then i'll
explain what policy of melons and
explain about how we actually go about
trying to do that so basically what we
want to do is to from over here to reach
a network that's the other side of the
world and the route basically propagate
across the internet and bgp as it
propagates them from from autonomous
system to autonomous system accumulates
an Aes path which basically record that
the path that the route actually took
the first main purpose of the a s path
is to be able to detect loops so
something basically comes back to an Aes
authority on the path you actually
detect that but this is sort of the
unimportant parts of bgp the other thing
the ice path is is used for is to the
front figure out well okay these routes
generally flood out across the internet
we have to figure out which one to use
so in this case SAS has received 11 way
also receives it another way and the s
path is is the first mechanism by which
you choose one route over the other
generally in absence of any other policy
you choose the shortest a/s path this is
the core mechanism of BGP no the
question is what about policy so here's
the root it flooded across the network
and it comes in over here well this may
be somebody's dial-up link or DSL line
or something like that so this is
probably a bad idea to accept that route
so the normal thing is that you you
would only accept a route here if it
came entirely from your customer not if
it came from other places so this is the
example
see that you might configure on a router
here to not accept certain types of
route other sort of policies you might
want to do this is an expert policy
don't export routes to to a provider
this guy doesn't want to export this
route because if he does this is some
small ISP this is AT&T and this is
sprint we don't really want to carry all
the Sprint AT&T traffic not really
enough financial interest here's another
one we get the route two different ways
which one will we prefer generally
prefer customer it's because they're
paying your money they're paying your
money you might as well use their roots
it's against in your finances all of
these are sort of things you need to
configure on on bgp to try and make this
stuff actually work so here are some
more specific examples of the sort of
things you generally speaking policy
breaks that into import filters and
export filters so examples of sort of
incoming filter filters would be to drop
the BGP roots if they have contained a
certain a s things like that also not
just to drop routes to change things you
might set the local preference field on
bgp or any of the other fields you might
want to set export filters again you
might want to say don't export routes to
a particular peer if they have a
particular community communities just
aware of tagging routes with some
arbitrary label so you don't AG them in
an import filter one side your network
and evaluate the phils the other side
and then things like this which is
actually fairly complicated when it
redistributed ospf routes that come from
particular OSP viet area to be GP and on
those routes to sets the the BG fees
multi-agency discriminator this isn't
actually a particular one you might want
to use but you can see the complication
here we're trying to build a policy
framework that's going to be able to
encompass just about any routing
protocol this one policy statement
basically has has to know about ospf it
has to know about things that are
totally ospf specific has to
redistribute route from one routing
protocol to another and set stuff on
those routes and she's totally bgp
specific and yet we don't want our
policy framework to have to know about
either ospf or bgp so the question is
how do you actually go about trying to
do this
thing and requires a certain might have
thought to figure out well what really
is required so if you look at the sort
of stage architecture that we have
actually it doesn't really matter quite
so much whether you take our
architecture anybody else's architecture
there are basically as the path that
roots take through a rotor they come in
from the outside world and so there's in
any routing protocol is kind of a
decision process goes on as to which
routes to actually use doesn't quite
look like this in the next eight routing
protocols but for vector based protocols
it does and so there's a point before
decision where you might want to be able
to interact with the roots there's a
point when you've actually chosen which
one to use where you might want to
interact with it then of course roots
come from different routing protocols
and you have to choose which one of
those is going to be used so the point
before and after that choice where you
might want to be able to interact with
orig and change it on the way out
similarly might want to interact it
before you figure out which winning you
want to choose some subset of routes
that you want to be redistribute on to
other routing protocols and then you
might want to interact with the ribs
again before you actually send them out
to the neighbor so there are all these
different possible places where you
might want to be able to change routes
and if you try and design a unified
policy framework that has to do with all
these different possible cases the
complex you get pretty hairy so after
spending a lot of time thinking about
this we've ended up with it with a
framework which it turns out you don't
actually do in fact with roots in all
those different places to implement it
just about everything we can think of
that anybody ever does it routing policy
so the first stage you want to implement
it is going to be for filter banks on
here but the first stage is basically
the point of ingress you want to be able
to reject routes you want to be able to
modify them before you've made a
decision as to which one to take because
you want to be able to set things like
the preference values all that sort of
thing so that's basically for import
filters and for import filthy won't be
able to match on a route there and you
also want to be able to modify the route
so the example I had earlier set the
local preference of bgp local preference
field of three on those incoming routes
if they have a certain BGP next stop
it's something that you would implement
entirely at this point it's an import
filter it gets entirely a pre decision
on on the routing protocols
export filters get complicated because
they have to deal with things with many
different pieces of state this example I
gave you just out which basically has
ospf specific information in there
that's basically some information about
where the RIT originated through the
base about where it's going to it's
going to be GP and also those roots have
to be distributed arm so it turns out
that the export policies that you
actually need to interact with the
region three different places the first
place need to interact with it is after
the routing protocols are decided which
routes of what of one you basically need
to be able to match certain subset of
those routes the second place you need
to be able to interact with it is in the
rib you need to figure out a subset of
those routes to be able to redistribute
onwards and you'll also notice that
actually conceptually this is one
routing protocol here and here so some
routes basically goes straight through
from one to the other without going
through the rib and bypass that the
third place you need to be able to
interact with this is you want to be
able to change rooms before they
actually go out to your neighbors or in
some cases just not forward them on so
that's basically the three different
place where you need to be either
interact with roots from one of your
export filters Dave I'll show you insane
okay so in the configuration part of the
rotor you basically need to be able to
take policies like this obviously
they're not written in English but you
take the tank policies like this and see
the big picture see how this basically
breaks down into into different pieces
of functionality need to go where so
there's basically a policy engine
there's going to look at these and
figure out what which bit of filtering
needs to happen where so the first thing
that will do is to configure the stage
to filter here and in this case we
configure that on our ospf and we're
basically saying match ospf roofs that
come from this area i'm going to tag
those with it with a arbitrary tag and
this tag space is a globally unique tag
space is allocated by the policy engine
so this is why you need to be able to do
it there is ospf is the only thing that
knows about ospf area
once it's in the rib you have no
information about ospf area the rib
doesn't know about routing protocols so
it can't know about that so this is the
point at which you want to be able to
interact with it now I knows which
protocol it came from but it doesn't
know anything that is specific to that
particular protocol because that would
okay you could probably design away the
ue carry opaque information through the
rib but once you get one through
carrying opaque information you might as
well deal with it in the place where it
actually knows how to deal with that
information so this case all you need to
basically do is to add these tags to the
roots as they come through and then you
can match arbitrary protocol specific
information the second place you need to
be able to do this is to configure the
filters in the rib to say we're going to
redistribute only some roots so we're
going to redistribute the roots that
happen to have this tag in this case
it's a fairly simple policy even though
I happens to be distributed one in the
third place is you want to be able to
set the med and that's basically it's a
BGP specific things so us bgp to do that
and that's basically how this policy
breaks down into these three different
places now the question is how do you
actually implement these policies down
inside each of these things and again
you want to be able to do this in such a
way that this is agnostic as to what
it's actually configuring so never get
into how the policy engine work the
first thing the policy engine does is
basically to take up complete reading
policy for the whole router and it can
figure out import filters go there
export / have you broken up into this
front part this two part and what we
actually do to the roots it doesn't
really know other than those which
routing protocols exist and it but then
loads basically a type map which
basically it's a lot bigger than this
but it basically says for a particular
protocol there are there are attributes
and certain types and some of those you
can modify in some of those you can only
look at but it doesn't know anything
more than this it just knows that there
are these attributes by name what their
types are to make sure that
we try to only those operators on things
which are correctly type and whether
they read write and basically what it
then does is to write a simple stack
machine program for each of those
filters the very simple programming
language that it writes and it downloads
that probe that I program into those
those filter banks so here we go the
policy manager in one of these films
event in one of the protocols and it
looks the same no matter which of the
protocols were actually in it has a this
generic stack wishing a field which
actually going to do all the work a
routes going to come in we're going to
run a little program over it and it's
going to do some work and then there
it's going to go on so the root comes
into your filter here the stack machine
gets it gets invoked and stack machine
basically says I want to read these
particular attributes from the root and
so it obtains these attributes by
basically asking for them by name is
then they modify those actually those
attributes may or defy some other
attributes it may say drop this route
all together things like that and then
once it's done that that the root can
continue on now the real key thing here
is that basically all the filters stage
one through four filters basically use
the same stack machine sent the same
little programming language so the
policy manager basically just has to
figure out which pizza pazza needs to go
where and make sure that it just figures
those this is basically just going to
ask for these attributes by names in a
rat them back by name it doesn't have to
know anything it's all the signs you
show you which names actually makes
sense has been done in the policy engine
for it by patents is basically a static
table of information and so if you're
implementing a routing protocol all you
have to do is to implement a filter
stage in your protocol and implement the
reader and the writer and they of course
our protocol specific it's a very small
piece of code to basically take a BGP
route and let's say pull out the a s
path or pull out the med and give it to
the stack machine so this means this you
can with very little code write a policy
filter for any routing protocol you're
writing all the complicated stuff of
difficult matching rules
that is handled basically by the stack
machine in a generic manner and it's not
tailored towards the region protocol
itself at all so that's basically that
the last of the three mains of the
design section I wanted to talk through
for you the basic I showed you the stage
design we've used for the BGP at the rib
which hopefully greatly encouraged
extensibility we certainly found it
useful when we've I'd want to add
functionality later on and hadn't
thought of it at the start talks through
very briefly the xrl inter-process
communication mechanism which lectures
actually use scripting languages for
testing and that sort of thing it also
allows us to use these template files
for extending our configuration language
talk through how that's a command-line
interface gets extended based on these
template files and briefly I've talked
through the policy routing framework so
the question you have to ask when you
find out sorry before I go hey Karen you
talk about forces it's a different part
of the problem space the this is control
plane functionality are words that is
the interface between the forwarding
engine and the control plane so all of
our work basically sits up there in the
control plane part and communicates down
with the with the forwarding engine I
won't click all the way back to the
Roman slide I hold him a long time to
get back here but the if you think back
to the block diagram I showed you and
start there was a box on their level f
EA and from our point of view all you
need to do to make up work function with
forces is to write the bottom end of the
FDA for forces and then we'll work on a
forces platform and that's basically all
you need to tell it to work on a
particular system because of this
architecture which tries to isolate the
routing protocol so they have to do
anything smart about talking to the net
or anything like that any privileges you
can really isolate them and they can be
very little damage this is the FAA then
the one place where you have to tailor
for a particular platform this also
turned out to be massively
useful we wanted to support this across
the windows and found the things weren't
quite as they were used to I can't
really discuss it in without having much
more specific so look at whether we've
whether it's something we have thought
of or not inevitably when you try and
design things we sent a bill to you you
attempt to do a good job you don't
always succeed in thinking of everything
anybody might want to do and so it's
hard to discuss in having the
hypothetical without really going and
seeing what they're trying to do there's
certainly no problem when I on an
architecture with running multiple
routing diamond and so forth there's no
problem in principle in money running
multiple ribs if you're forwarding plane
has some way of dealing with multiple
groups but we've never done that and
it's down the line somewhere for Road
active do that kind of functionality so
just some simple and simple performance
numbers before we finish and one of the
things we wanted to look at was with how
long it actually takes from from a
period coming into how to actually that
getting into the into the kernel so this
graph basically was a very simple test
we fired in 200 and something routes one
a second and got a new instrument of the
code to find out where them wearing the
code the root pass its at certain times
so the red dots on here are how long it
took the route to actually no wrong
rewind I'll get onto that one in a
second the x-axis here is the route
number the y-axis is how long it took in
milliseconds to for the route to come
very first to be seen by bgp to actually
being into the kernel and the different
colors on here basically show the the
load that the rotor had at the
particular moment of time in terms of
reading table size so the red ones here
basically show when the when the rotor
hi
unloaded treating tables or effect could
be empty although there is a next hop
already resolved so we don't have to go
and ask about that one and it's around
3.1 milliseconds from when we first see
the route we actually end up in the
kernel and then the colored ones are
basically Walt just to see whether we
actually got the computational
complexity right in these different
parts of the protocols how much longer
does it take if we have a full bgp feed
at 160,000 routes so the green is
basically where where these routes are
coming in on a pier which actually has
held the 160,000 routes and the blue
ones are when it comes in on a different
pearbook but another peer hundred sixty
thousand routes and you can see there's
a very small change of a lot less than a
millisecond as you go from an unloaded
riff to a loaded Ritter so this I think
generally shows that we were pretty fast
in terms of whenever it appears how long
it takes us to actually go through these
different stage things through BGP
through the RHIB through the FBI and
down into the kernel it's interesting
question where the time goes and this
graph attempts to break that down
although inevitably by instrumenting it
you probably affect the thing you're
trying to instrument this is basically
showing that the route basically came in
and then the red on here is when bgp
cues it to go to the rib the green on
here is when b2b thinks it's sent it to
the rib the blue is when it's actually
as time is arriving at the ribbon and so
for us as it goes through and what you
actually see on here is that the it
spends very little time in each of the
actual protocols so the majority of the
timer is it's really that the protocol
is doing something and then we go to
context switch and something else
happens and so forth
this is with a full piya o ok that's a
different question so but these graphs
basically tried to show is for a single
route when we have a large table how
long does that take you're what you're
asking is when a reader comes up how
longs it take to give you 160 thousand
roots I don't think I have the numbers
off top of my head you know 10 minutes
on a very slow machine we haven't put
much effort interviewing any
optimization of any of this stuff at the
moment the 10 minutes I believed was
still when we weren't even pipelining
because obviously you get a big win here
when that happens when you pipeline a
lot of routes between the different
protocols and for a while we were having
some stability problems with the
enterprise communication so we turned
off the pipelining and I think that 10
minutes still has that but it's good to
problems and now be resolved and I don't
think we've actually done any tailoring
to get the pipelining working as well as
we ought to do again the pipelining will
work much better once we actually sort
of that our scheduling details to make
sure that we actually do get stuff into
the PI line before you do a context
switch so I think we have a lot of
covers that we can get those number down
by quite a bit but I don't know where
they're going to end up this one is
going back to this question of being
event-driven versus scanner driven again
we have roots arriving once a second and
the question here is from when a root
first of either bgp to when is actually
passed on to a bgp neighbor and what we
have here is Azure mitd a fairly old
cisco routine now do you remember what
is actually 12 point something anyway
and and quagga and if you look on here
the what you see is this wonderful
patterning which is the root scanner
running so some roots arrive and the
roots can run immediately some buds
arriving the roots Gandalf number 30
seconds so you obviously get this nice
linear decrease and you can see that a
mighty beanz or par basically
persistently down here
leave a few milliseconds a time scale
and quack oh and the cisco Rooter are
you got an average delay a 15 seconds
before the neighborhood one before you
bother to tell your neighbor that you've
actually just heard something that you
want to use so that's just the
properties that you see at the ritz gun
is really obvious in this kind of graph
I believe newer Cisco operating systems
and reading code are moving toward
evening event driven as well so I can't
say that all Cisco's of this bad but
there's been some research on that
although it's one of the experiments
it's very hard to do without having this
sort of stuff deployed because you don't
have any instrumentation points in the
network but the the general conclusion
is that the delay of root scanners is
very bad from the point of view of
convergence and the dynamics of the
internet because these days tend to
accumulate across the network but they
let something happen at one space and we
have another place but I'm hand waiting
here because there isn't really a lot of
understanding as to exactly how these
things really impact the world the other
thing is making that route flap damping
which also seem to have a fairly serious
adverse effect on on the way the doubts
of the intellectual function it's
probably the wrong mechanism to use is
to try and actually slow the propagation
of reading information the better
mechanism is to not generate an awful
lot of churn in the first place and that
means you want to be suppressing it
close to the origin whereas trying to
slow things half down way through the
network is the wrong place to generally
do with that kind of problem but that's
it's easy to add delays hard to remove
delay from the system so I think you you
basically want design the system so they
very functional no delay as far as
possible but you can even add delays
later if they're shown to be a good
thing so in terms of current status the
is a fair amount of functionality here
that we now consider to be pretty stable
bgp for v4 and v6 rip for v4 v6
so again v4 and v6 igmp v2 MLD the v6
the ribbon and the management framework
are all pretty stable now ospf for
policy framework and is is are in
progress ISS is not on our immediate
high priority list but ospf in the
policy framework will be we hope stable
by the end of the summer platforms that
was ported on basically most of the BS
DS and Linux and the the windows port is
in progress archana will probably tell
you more about exactly what in progress
means here but basically to rough
approximation means the unicast routing
protocols and working the multicast ones
out and the command-line interface is
not working but everything else is v6 is
not working but we'll get to that one so
to summarize here designing for
extensibility is actually quite
difficult it requires you to really
think about things from day one it's not
something you can have a retrofit it's
an architectural thing that has to pull
me actually the whole design I don't
have any good metrics as you tell you
about how you evaluate extensibility the
the only really good information we have
is anecdotal evidence for people who
have tried to apply as up stuff that we
didn't expect and they've come to
conclusions is actually it's very good
for doing this sort of stuff the always
this issue to do with modularity and
sensibility versus performance and this
is inevitably a trade-off that you have
to decide where you are in that space
for routing software very high
performance matters less than the fact
that you actually scale well to very
large routing tables and it's not the
same internet that it was a decade ago
in terms of the balance between routing
information and and CPUs with a lot more
CPU power now than we've ever had arm in
the past relative to the size of the
routing tables now this doesn't
necessarily apply to backbone Reuters
where you're trying to change Hardware
forwarding passes very high rates but
it's into the control plane because we
actually have a more CPU cycles
available in that really changes the
landscapers of the balance of power here
really only time he's going to tell if
it's all B's ever adopted widely enough
to change the way protocols are
developed tested deployed and so forth
we've been doing this for five years now
and it's really the last six to nine
months where the traffic on the main
list had really started to take off and
lots people start to deploys up in
interesting ways I think at this stage
pretty much all of them are academic or
research but that's what we need you
basically people to try it out find
where things really work and don't work
and the bugs to get fixed them that way
the software will get stable enough to
see deployment in the and the wider
Internet so thanks to all the people who
have worked on zouk over the last few
years and it's going to be a lot more
years and had a hope those of us with
blue here are here today otter new
pavlin Bruce and thanks to everybody who
has funded salt too including Microsoft
questions more questions
yeah yes I spoke quite a long time in
standard process the ITF as you guys
have you the the question in terms of
writing specs is how much to use how
much do you specify implementation
versus how much you specified just the
mineral need for interoperability and I
think that from the point of view of the
standards documents it is probably right
to specify the minimum needed for
interoperability but that doesn't mean
that it can't be additional documents
that can help people out do good quality
implementations the the problem in the
past always was basically the only way
to interoperate the cisco was to or a
live in trouble with anyone basically to
interoperate with cisco and test against
their implementations and it really
wasn't a cisco his interest to write
good specs they I wouldn't go is quite
so far as to say they deliberately wrote
bad specs but they they had no real
incentive not to the existence of
Juniper rather changed that and if you
look at the BGP specs for instance
they've got a lot better over the last
few years the rewrite the newbie chicken
spec is much much closer to documenting
a useful subset of the functionality and
what's actually deployed it's still
pretty minimal in the whole bunch of
useful places where you would like more
information the ospf spec actually is
not too bad from the implantation for
interview looks like they actually tried
fairly what fairly hard to help
implement us out but I think that's the
it certainly the specs are deficient and
we could do better but and you do want
to separate out what is required from
how you how you might implement it
because otherwise you seriously
prejudiced how you actually go about
building something if you especially if
I how you implement it rather than what
it needs to interoperate is tricky gain
the standards game to avoid getting
caught up in all the antitrust mess and
so forth but I think some information
Laura sees for example would really help
people and they wouldn't be mandatory
they would just be helpful
yeah well even though the other Cusco
I'm wizard the other classical one was
was diploma to multicast where
anyway my point is that there are spaces
like march past and v6 where people want
to experiment with the very queries of
marginal compensatory maybe it's a drop
in azure fruits were advocating for
example we had intended by this stage at
our own border to be runs or bruises so
we have we're running out door is open
v6 since we soon as we've got the policy
story in polished we will run errands
done to the boards over time no it'd be
a victim but it's a good question so I
can I can argue that it's better than
the past but I can't argue that it's
sufficient I mean the classic example
that you and I spent a lot of time
dealing with multicast and loads of ISPs
refuse tell a multicast because they
could dig if anything my I think went
wrong with pivot rotation then the BGP
will go down in architecture like this
there is pretty much no way that the pin
space going to go take bgp down it's
generally things are sufficiently well
isolated in terms of whether the weather
pins multicast might then overload your
network with traffic that's a different
question and it doesn't give you that
form of protection but most of these
ISPs along the same wires man multicast
and unicast traffic so they obviously
weren't too concerned about that one
they were more concerned about the red
bgp going down um anecdotal evidence but
nothing more i mean if you go and talk
to folks in down dog there a lot of the
time they're really fairly scathing
about the stability of anything other
than in a fatty world tested to a small
subset available from county it's
primarily because of crashes
so we would be that that bad we would be
robust to the other thing that we can do
have if you're looking vegetable is that
experimental you can actually run
another box so if it's gone it's going
to take all the sleep angry without any
of the other no because we can actually
take one Rooter and move a routing
protocol to a different box we can run a
distributed route and isolate that radio
protocol we're also playing around with
running as or binders n so we can just
use the virtualization environment to
really isolate and bound a region
protocol I can't say we're at the point
where we're running back yet but I've a
student who's working on it and that
will be with an even stronger story in
terms of how much we can protect the
rest of the data from something very bad
on that router but again doesn't doesn't
protect the network which is something
which it might imprints will be possible
to do but in practice it's probably
there's too much of a coupling there
with the forwarding plane and exactly
what you do in terms of rate limiting on
the forwarding and so forth for us to be
able to solve that problem in the
control plane I think that it may be
possible to do too in a region where you
control both the forwarding plane and
the control plane you may be able to
mitigate that issue but it doesn't seem
to me that it's the main issue but of
course it may be for some people not
I don't think we've done enough analysis
if the download logs to know for sure
who has been downloading it the traffic
on the mailing list is an interesting
mixture of people from various academic
places and we suspect although we don't
know for sure that a number of the the
Chinese vendors are quite interested
they seem to have been asking fairly
cryptic questions on the mailing list so
we don't really know exactly what their
interest is but it would be interesting
to see how that plays out in terms of
number of downloads do you actually call
off the top of your head it's my
recollection is that the last time we
got slashed out and it was in the region
of many of several thousand the copies
of the live CD were downloaded in about
six hours but I don't have the overall
total numbers there's a live CD absorb
which lets you stick a CD in it and
we'll run a freebsd kernel with it's all
running on top of it out of the box for
that Emmett now compile or run a nine
so it
so I'd still with the man I won first it
was something that we didn't consider
from the outset it just wasn't on our
radar for some reason it should have
been and then there was a guy in Canada
I forget why his institution was who to
absorb and decided to use it for dealing
some ad hoc routing and the one problem
he found was that we were assuming
basically that you had specified next
hop by subnet and that doesn't work if
you don't have subnet based addressing
so we that was one case where we had
missed something what or what we added
was the ability to specify by the rib
eye subnet by our just interface as an
exile by interface and and that problem
went away and he as far as we can tell
was very successful in using it in his
particular case I'm not sure the zorp
actually helped him all that much but we
did actually merge this apportionment as
for the the business on other forwarding
hardware I think the answer is at this
point we don't have a lot of experience
with it with the the FAA was designed to
provide that isolation there so we can
tailor it towards different forwarding
paths but all of the forwarding paths
that we've spent much time dealing with
our software forwarding paths so be we
obviously have experienced with a number
of different UNIX kernels and using
those as forwarding paths we also
experience with a click which is Eddie
colon rob morris is very modular
software forwarding paths where you
can't reconfigure different elements and
so forth and more recently move engaging
experience with using windows as a
forwarding paths but we don't actually
have any direct experience at this point
of using sort of switches or things like
that oh the stuff that the radio Berman
was suggesting I honestly don't know
enough about it to comment on it I know
its existence but that's about how is
this something specific about it that
might be an issue or does it just the
life and beyond
yeah was it layer 2 or less three here
but it was still but it was layer to
forward it wasn't it yeah so basically
all was open not going to help you very
much for that problem because soap is
really intended to be an IP router and
so its concept of forwarding and stuff
like that in the existing implementation
is very well embedded with the concept
of using IP for doing forwarding so it's
not going to help with that problem it's
not that it would say yeah
microchip returned one isn't hope you
told me so we came a few months ago to
demonstrate zorp running we produced our
power box connected to a freebsd machine
back in XE and then suddenly looked at
the horror on people's faces will be
discovered that we were expected to
actually shows up running on windows so
hopefully this time we will fix that bug
memorize that while we just set a couple
of things up so what the demonstration
that we want to do is we want to
describe replacing your junipers at the
border with machines running Windows
2000 2000 and orb so these are the two
border Reuters this what did I say okay
close this and this and this is your ISP
and all of our experiments are going to
be run from host 16 and I'm just going
to switch inputs yes you can refer back
to it can you can and so lose that lose
the windows for a second and so on this
side we're going to just run pings from
traceroutes from hoses 16 and on this
side we're going to control this router
okay so just so let me go back to the
other diagram memorize that and we'll
just start couple things running
so yes so where we've just started zorp
running here and here let's look at the
network so the so our network
configuration as I described earlier is
your to our to order Reuters here nice p
out there and a test host let me just so
we should be able to from host 16 ping
our ISPs a bruiser one second patent ok
Pavan could you ping the water route oh
haha that's the nice thing about demos
isn't it so but it's ok the reason that
the ping is not going through is that we
aren't running zorp on this router yet
so I'm going to switch inputs or not
they're here we go havlin could you
start the door please and watch the
watch the ER that's not that's not good
ok try that again so we are so using the
remote desktop to talk to za one watch
the ping at the ok you've got no pain so
when we ok here we go so we're going to
a so a starting zorp so these are
windows binaries on on sort one study
starting up so the ruta manager is going
through and starting the various modules
that mark told you about earlier there
we go bgp rip and then magically the
ping will start running and it is
okay where's my oh ok left it here
where's my with my crib sheet ok so
let's paneling would you like to log in
to zorp 1 so this is our shell took that
controls the Rooter we don't have the
shell running on windows yet but because
of the XR l's we can actually on host 16
run the command line and control the
Rooter so can you show me the
configuration section so we have rip
enabled in the configuration and if you
go down to the okay to go down to the
BGP configuration can you show me we
don't have the BGP reap earrings enabled
at the moment and could you show me the
routing table please and we have command
line completion in our and there we are
and you can see the that no network is
being announcing rip okay
sir next I'm going to just switch back
to the going to switch back to the
slides a second fourth sort of in so
we've done the ping test we've started
to up so rip is enable Beatrice
available Britain temple contains that
route I was expecting to be able to
display both at the same time ok so
what's going to happen so we're bringing
up appearing with our isp we need to
verify that if anything goes wrong that
the routing will continue to run so
we're going to actually disconnect
disconnect desorb one from the from our
isp let me just switch back so you can
see that the ping is running from the
from ho 16 to error to our isp now
please don't do this at home I'm going
to pull out this cable and the ping is
going to stop and instantaneously the
routing is going to cut over ok maybe
maybe it isn't so we've actually
configured it for 15 seconds we actually
want you to show you that the other big
stops here we are back in place so good
so can you should do a traceroute for me
ok so we're going the so we're going the
wrong way long way around host 16 dog
buns up for border can you ok keep keep
running the trace roots I'm going to put
the cable back in
hmm okay good so routines converge the
cable is back in and I'm oh you can't
see the slides ok so the rips / 50
seconds the ping is now running you can
see the new written to our let me that
have been showing the new routing table
haha ok and now
okay that's what we just did okay so now
we want to see if we could we need to
see we can of so now we have we're going
to connect and we're going to enable bgp
on zorb one and as soon as we enable bgp
on zorp one we should be able to see
external roots so we're going to start a
ping to an external route okay so so we
have a sort of so we have a I guess we
have juniper like syntax and now pavlin
is going to go to the beach p config and
enable a bid to enable the two bgp
pairings so that we have an ibgp peering
to our neighboring router and ebgp ring
to the ISP router
and as with juniper when you make a
change we don't we don't send the chain
we don't circuits okay we don't send the
change immediately and you can see that
the that the two two parcels of conflict
that we've changed our highlighted so if
you now cap it if you now commit the
change the pink should start running
good and if you show me the BGP routing
table so we're only at the moment we're
just advertising that one that one
network go yet so and you can see the
route has received both both from on the
ibgp during an on the ebgp Bering okay
their questions
so we expect to have the ipv6 working at
the at the moment we are not using the
roots or manager be to interface to
install the roots and we were hoping to
talk to you guys today about how we can
do that we thought we've we've we've had
problems with the with the online
documentation it looks like we need to
see some example code but how to drive
it and so if we could have an
interaction on that that would be very
that would be very useful we will get
the dope show running actually on
windows so the problem that we hit was
we didn't realize that we our event loop
is based on select and we hadn't
realized that select was not going to do
the job for us if we have both ipv4 and
ipv6 and it also isn't going to do the
job for us for listening for the
keyboard on windows so we're going to
reef at to that backing code and then
that's one of the issues with his or
shop so but refactor the backing code
and we should have a full story we're
not sure about Marta cost we're still
waiting for you guys to get back with
this would be interfaces but we expect
by October to have a pretty full story
we haven't checked what we have into the
tree yet we're going to do we're going
it from we can we can make if somebody
wants what we have at the moment we can
make that available
but we have but but and Bruce have a
roofs had an interesting question with
them actually let me show you can you go
to the top of the config so if you see
that our interfaces have interesting
valuable interestinger and we've
actually used the interface ID at the
moment so that we have a mapping to this
kind of the unique light space and I'm
told that's that art that and that
identifier is different for these six as
well yeah so does anyone have any ideas
yeah yeah so does so do you have any
thoughts about how we can do the but
that's what Bruce was talking about
doing here now we thought about having a
separate attributed
there's something this is there
something that's fixed right okay okay
and we're and we are so you're saying
something different happens on longhorn
oh okay so if we were to say that in the
future we only works on long-haul and
then we could deal with we could deal
with the thing that we were the naming
that we were right okay and just if the
user decides to rename something that's
the users problem
how many places but if you keep down to
smoke people very much so this should we